october is breast cancer awareness month
it's estimated one in eight women will
get that dreaded diagnosis so in today's
buddy check a report denise valdez tells
us the step you should take to find the
right doctor if you ever get that
diagnosis
recently breastcancer.org talked to
three doctors oncologists and surgeons
who had breast cancer the role is kind
of reversed for them they got to see
what it was like to be a patient but
then they also learned a few things in
finding the right cancer team for them i
call myself
a dual citizen
a doctor and a patient
breastcancer.org founder and chief
medical officer marissa weiss sharing
observations with other physicians on
their breast cancer journey i learned
that
the doctor-patient relationship is so
sacred
i mean
you are really trusting someone to
protect and cherish your life and your
life is your greatest gift each expert
recommends meeting with a few doctors if
you can ask for referrals read reviews
and come prepared upon that initial
meeting someone who has the expertise
the judgment the knowledge the
experience that you need in order to get
the best care possible the best care
means the greatest benefits and the
least side effects a doctor who listens
to you hears you takes you seriously and
will help get you back to the person you
were before the diagnosis the only way
that i was going to get the care that i
needed was to advocate for myself to
find my voice to speak up although it's
a club none of them wanted to be in they
came out the other side with a better
understanding of what it's like to be a
patient and a survivor for buddy check
denise valdez live local now